- Well, I have to ask,
how do you feel about being a popular meme
in the last few years?
Because there's a lot of good ones,
there's you sipping tea.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As they say in the social media circles,
it's not that easy being meme.
(Kelly laughs)
But, you know,
there's something about a frog
sipping tea that speaks to everybody.
- This is like a little
star Wars kind of thing.
I like this one.
- Yeah, that's a picture of,
that's me and my evil
doppelganger, Constantine the Frog,
from "Muppets Most Wanted."
- Oh my God, I love it.
I love it.
Well, it's been a challenging year.
So what do the Muppets
want everyone to know?
- You know what, Kelly, I
think we've all discovered
that even when we're not
together in the same place,
we can still check in with each other
and take care of each other
and if we do that every day,
then we'll get through this
and we'll be a bit
better for it, you know?
- Yeah. I love the optimism.